les séries je vous racontais trois
histoires extraordinaires comme tous les
soirs
histoire que je vous racontais
maintenant bafoue toutes les règles de
la morale et nous renvoie aux origines
les plus sombres de l'humanité
vous parlez tel mois la première
histoire du jour ce travail et beinheim
de les voir c'est rien du tout 1
c'est beau c'est huit heures par jour et
voilà exactement histoire du jour c'est
une évasion incroyable les faits se sont
déroulés dans le comté de cook comté de
maeva pour échapper à la prison
un jeune forcené prénommé jaser scott z
jay scott jackez on va là p marketscope
s'est servi des mesures sanitaires dus à
l'épidémie de coronavirus pour se faire
la malle pour cela ni regarder cette
histoire qui est folle oui regardez vous
mais vous êtes déjà évadé de quelque
part ou batterie mois de l'émission
passe aussi aussi si vous en avez marre
de devoir porter un masque à chacun de
vos déplacements en raison de la
situation sanitaire certains ont réussi
à faire de ce petit désagrément un
avantage de taille
jack et scott 21 ans était un détenu de
la prison du comté de cook dans
l'illinois arrêté pour coups et
blessures sur un agent de police et
détention illégale d'une arme
il était libérable sous caution pour un
montant de 50 mille dollars mais
histoire de faire des économies et
quitté la prison plus rapidement il a
profité de la situation du moment pour
proposer un codétenu queen teen
henderson qui lui devait être libéré le
jour même de prendre sa place contre
1000 euros un deal que queen teen
henderson a accepté et pour se faire
passer pour lui ni vu ni connu
cech et scott a simplement porter un
masque de protection un stratagème qui a
fonctionné à merveille
aujourd'hui il est un homme libre en
cavale certes mais libre en revanche
quand ils aiment personne lui est
toujours en prison accusés d'avoir aidé
jack et scott à s'évader
sa caution s'élève maintenant à 25 mille
dollars
r ouais ouais ouais vous avez vu cette
histoire extraordinaire et franchement
non mais oh les mecs savent outre ou le
savent où trouver le popotin les grands
comme toute émission alors
[Rires]
l'élégantissime comme bakary ça qui va
du saucisson de sa wii est la raison
isabelle parce qu'il y en a un des deux
qui est le dindon de la farce parce
qu'il y en a un des deux qui finalement
se retrouve en prison et qui a aidé et
l'autre à ses fans et qui va avoir une
peine supplémentaire donc c'est normal
merci en tout cas franchement vous me
demanderez vous histoire que je vais
vous raconter maintenant bafoue toutes
les règles de la morale et les renvoie
aux origines est plus sombre de sûreté
les spectateurs l'histoire que je vous
racontais maintenant la folle afu bafoue
toutes les règles de la morale
hier et nous renvoie aux origines peu
sombre de l'humanité pour cette seconde
histoire à vous raconter l'incroyable
subterfuge qu'un jeune homme a mis en
place pour échapper aux contrôles de
police à l'aéroport
jacques ascot malgré sa créativité
les jeunes garçons s'est fait prendre
regardez c'est une histoire qui va vous
intéressez vous et vous l'élégantissime
regarder avec la crise sanitaire que
traverse le monde chacun essaye de
s'organiser pour pouvoir continuer à
vivre
c'est le cas de cet américain qui s'est
clairement cru dans un film un jeune
homme originaire de washington dont la
petite copine vit en allemagne
après de longues semaines de confinement
il a décidé de prendre son courage à
deux mains et de défier les consignes
interdisant les voyages touristiques en
europe c'est donc en prétextant un
voyage professionnel qu'il a voyagé vers
francfort arrivés à l'aéroport ils
avaient tout prévu enfile un gilet jaune
à porter des sacs poubelle à la main
et se faire passer discrètement pour un
agent d'entretien de l'aéroport son plan
aurait pu fonctionner s'il n'avait pas
oublié deux petits détails
en effet au moment du contrôle les
agents de sécurité se sont aperçus
qu'ils ne portaient pas de badge mais
surtout qu'il ne parlait pas allemand du
coup le subterfuge n'a pas fonctionné
longtemps machine arrière il est reparti
vers washington aussi vite qu'ils
étaient arrivés du ballet et ça alors ça
c'est incroyable qu'il ferait appel
survient presque faire un film
allez c'est sûr c'est une bonne idée de
scénario il y avait une petite boîte de
production cinar non mais vous oui ben
moi je produis tout ce que vous voulez
enfin là c'est un court métrage c'est
d'y aller et puis ne va pas non à
desquels on peut dormir des heures
caroline ithurbide trop belle preuve
d'amour moi franchement j'aurais été ému
et j'aurais franchement je regardais le
mec sur le territoire je l'aurait
autorisé à voir sa copine way s'est
montré une belle preuve d'amour enfin si
tout le monde veut faire une preuve
d'amour à ce moment là arrêtons tout
arrêter regarder et l'élégant l'avait à
la fois il a pris son camion sont calmes
tard il allait à 40 kilomètres qui l'a
ramenée du sauciflard à sa copine mais
voilà c'est moi oui
caroline turbie quelle est la plus belle
preuve d'amour qu'on vous ait fait bas
mes enfants je pense non mais je pense
encore dévolues qu'on ait voulu que ce
soit la mère de deux enfants il voulait
il voulait il voulait que ça d'accord
c'est donc elle qui est une salle dans
l'émission ça
ah mais on son cas
une force pas les chiffres alors que si
on rigole bien un truc très gentil sur
lui même énormément votre mari vous le
voulez avec un baiser il me dit je
préfère être malheureux avec toi qu
heureux avec une autre nom voilà c'est
pas d'autres marie sissi olive et tom y
en a deux ou trois comme ça en 45 nm dès
2 ou 3 quand c'est lui qui avait sa wii
et donc il peut pas être heureux avec
toi aussi
si sa maladie soit possible allez je
vous racontais une troisième histoire
histoire que je vous racontais
maintenant 2 alors ça rigole je vous
racontais une troisième histoire
histoire que je vous racontais
maintenant bafoue toutes règles morales
et nous renvoie aux origines et plus
sombres de l'humanité
cette histoire elle concerne lola et
fabrice un jeune couple qui a profité du
confinement pour faire un enfant
l'occasion de dire un bon jour à phil
barney dans un seul enfant de toi
c'est le cas d'un don je rêvais seul
enfant que dieu seul enfant de toi c'est
le cadeau que j'attendais elle est en
dérangement est ce que vous disiez et
pour que cette période reste gravé dans
leur mémoire ils ont trouvé une idée
regardez
l'idée qu'ils ont trouvée car l'histoire
que vous allez voir bafouer toutes
règles morales et nous renvoient aux
sombres de l'humanité
regardez c'est une séquence diffusée sur
france inter qui a beaucoup fait rire
les auditeurs de la station pourtant il
ne s'agit pas d'un sketch fabrice et
lola ont répondu aux questions d'un
journaliste sur les coulisses de leur
confinement visiblement dans ce couple
il a fait grand bien à leur libido
clairement la première semaine
c'était chaleur à ibiza une promiscuité
qui a porté ses fruits puisque suite à
ce rapprochement la jeune femme est
tombée enceinte
une nouvelle qui semble lui avoir fait
plaisir mais sans excès de reproduire ça
parce que moi mon objectif c'est de ne
pas en avoir un troisième
mais c'est du côté créativité que ses
parents ont marqué les esprits car si
cet enfant a été conçue pendant le
confinement low life fabris veulent à
tout prix qu'il s'en souvienne c'est la
raison pour laquelle ils ont pour projet
de lui donner en deuxième prénom qu'aux
vidéos ou co vida en fonction du sexe
on s'est dit que ça pourrait être drôle
et puis comme ça les gens sauraient dès
se rappelleraient on lui souhaite déjà
bon courage et cette histoire est folle
un sérieux vous voulez réagir là-dessus
week au vidage temps passa plus con
qu'un courage quand il avait appelé sa
fille marie clafoutis permet ce pagne
est plein de conception d'une carte
nationale pour une fois ça pourrait être
drôle non deuxième près d'un mur weimar
et non mais après quand elle sera grande
j'espère qu'on aura oublié s'il avait
conçu le jour où il avait la chasse ils
ont rappelé comment chat ça dans la
nature
allez dans la nature vous allez dans les
fleurs là bas vous avez dans l'alabama
dont ils furent loi à l'appareil photo
reste à aller un peu dans les fleurs pac
déclare si halloween à orly on s'en fout
en fait important de l'histoire c'est
que ils ont fait l'amour
et moi je me suis rendu compte d'un truc
c'est que les gens pleins mais les gens
pensent que pendant le confinement il ya
chement d'activité sexuelle faut savoir
que à la moitié des français en couple
qu'ils n'ont pas fait l'amour pendant le
confinement les mercis on n'a pas envie
de savoir est ce pas je peux vous dire